The Joe Rogan Experience you heard Woody
Harrison on SNL did you see that
immediately after Woody Harrelson had
that monologue on SNL where he's joking
around
about a drug company forcing you to take
their drug right after it the next day
there's all these hit pieces like like
they were timed like this pit piece and
fox is a hit piece in Vanity Fair it was
a hit piece calling him an anti-vaxxer
and a stoner and sucked on Cheers
conspiracy theories he's pushing
conspiracy theories no he's no no no no
that's not what he's doing he's a joke
monologue on SNL about something that
makes people laugh because you can kind
of make a weird comparison to those two
that's the only reason why the joke
works yeah the only reason why it works
is because people are thinking it like
so for you guys to come out and say like
oh conspiracy if you're saying doesn't
no it's jokes about a possible
conspiracy theory
and the one that he's describing isn't
having it's not even a real one he's
making a joke about what the real one
was like
maybe not the best joke maybe not the
best delivery but the fact that that got
this immediate response where all these
people defend the pharmaceutical
companies they're all jumping in and
defending them like in unison they're
all anti-vaxxer stoner
and you know instead of saying it sucked
or instead of saying hey stick to acting
instead you know no it's like
they all wanted to jump in to defend the
vaccine
they all wanted to jump in and defend
the pharmaceutical companies from this
anti-vaxxer stoner
actor who's talking it's just
interesting that they all take that
route
I get criticized in the monologue but
all taken that route that's an anti-vasc
conspiracy Jerry look is it
no it's he's joking about a way things
went down yeah like there's a lot to
what he's saying like forcing you to
take their drug like that kind that kind
of was happening and if you weren't
getting forced you were certainly
getting coerced you're getting urged on
by the government
there was probably a commercial for a
medicine right after that yeah probably
right away right away
it's not like they're not spending money
on all this stuff like like why are we
pretending
and so when he makes that joke
and he talks about them buying all the
media
and then all the media responses if
they've been bought and paid for that's
pretty wild
there's so many articles written about
them like right away yeah I was like
this is crazy I always look at both
sides and CNN had it but also CNN is
owned by the same company that owns SNL
So It's tricky because they don't want
to make them look bad
but they you know
angled it like it was him yeah even
though what we know is that these
scripts are approved days in advance
yeah they had to prove that unless you
went out and Dave chappelled it
yeah he he didn't Dave had two different
monologues
e Dave ran one monologue by everybody
and killed and they're like this is
great then he goes on Friday does a
whole separate one oh
God bless him
God bless him because Woody Harrelson
did that God bless him but you know look
the fact that everybody jumped in like
that was just very interesting